Another black coach in the NFL.
Out. Houston Texans firing Lovie Smith
after just one season.
Smith ended his run on a high note
by pulling off a Last-Minute
comeback to cap off a three
13 and one season on Sunday.
But the victory cost the team a
to secure the first overall pick
in this year's
NFL draft,
which goes to the team
with the league's worst record.
So Smith is the second black hea
coach fired in Houston
in as many years in the franchis
Let go David Culley last year.
ESPN's Stephen
Smith says the Texans have not b
the Houston organ, the Houston
Texans organization are an atroc
They are an embarrassment.
And as far as I'm concerned,
if you're an African-American
and you aspire to be a head coac
in the National Football
League, this 31 teams, you shoul
you should hope for.
You should hope beyond God
that the Houston Texans never ca
And joining us
now is Bob
Jones, the host of Game Theory
with Bomani Jones,
which will kick off
season two
on HBO and HBO Max
next Friday, January 20th.
I think Stephen wakes up.
Good morning.
Everybody is ready to get up. He
But seriously, though, I mean, d
he have a point?
Because after Lovie Smith
took this job last February,
you said that
you had no reason to believe
that this would be lasting.
Did you see this coming?
Why did you say that?
Oh, because the whole organizati
is a dumpster fire.
Like,
the thing about it is I'm
not exactly sure who should take
or he says no
black friends to take that job.
I would recommend a white man
take that job either.
Now, with Lovie
Guy, it
you have to remember
where it was going around
that they were thinking about hi
Josh McCown,
who was a former NFL quarterback
whose only coaching
experience is in high school.
And it looked really bad
while the league was being sued
for discrimination
about his hiring practices with
What did happen is Lovie Smith,
who has an impeccable resume,
wound up getting the job,
but nobody was going to give him
and anybody else
was going to give him a head
coaching job.
So what the Texans are
is a job where I think the last
they've hired black dudes largel
because no
self-respecting white
man would go take that job
like they were down
to the people who they felt like
had to take the job.
David Culley,
whose name had never come up
in a coaching discussion before.
And then Lovie Smith,
who probably had his last chance
So that's how you get
why would he take it his
this is his last chance.
Why would Lovie take this job?
It pays better than not being
a head coach.
Like that was when David Kelly g
Like, why would he take it?
Because it pays a lot better to
in a receivers coach.
But there are big questions abou
I mean, they went through in 30.
I mean, they had a disastrous se
and they had four have head coac
There have been, um, four search
this in four years. Right?
So it's a whole
nother conversation
about the Houston Texans overall
and what a disaster they are int
But it does raise questions
and put a spotlight
on the diversity in the NFL,
which we just talked about
when we launched the show
and what that looked like.
And also with Brian Flores
And so I wonder what the spotlig
of the takeaways from
this are given his firing.
Well, I think we're going to
it'll be easier for us
to talk about the takeaways
after we get through this hiring
There are five jobs
that are open and we'll see who
Getting the jobs
with their backgrounds are
and everything else.
The thing that happens every yea
when coaching jobs come around
is we effectively
wind up having the same discussi
every single year about it
because the problem is the same
every single year about it.
But rarely do the individual det
matter that much.
It's a big,
grand macro
tracking issue
that gets us to where we are
with the lack of coaches of colo
in the NFL, which is better,
I think now than it was
maybe three years ago.
Probably not
as good as it was about 15 years
It's only going to change
as much as the owners of the fra
actually wanted to change it.
If they recognized this
as a macro level problem.
They did recognize that 20 years
I don't think they recognize it
as much now,
but I think they recognize it
more than they did five or six y
But it's it's a vicious circle,
It's the black owners,
black coaches, it's all connecte
Well, I think the cycle is very
to the Voting Rights Act cycle.
Which is you look up
and you think things are good en
to where, hey,
we don't need to pay that much a
to these safeguards
that we have in place
to make sure fairness is there.
We could just throw that out.
People have gotten better,
and the next thing you know, you
and everything is what it was be
The same thing we saw
with affirmative action
in education is that
that's the point that you get to
So when the Rooney Rule first ca
they should really call it
the Johnnie Cochran rule
because they were afraid
that Johnnie Cochran
was going to take them to court.
And he doesn't scare
white people at that time
more than the idea that Johnnie
is going to take you to court.
He was a magician. Right.
But they put the rule in there o
they did put that rule in.
You saw a lot of black coaches g
You saw some changes happen.
Then after a while,
gradually people stop
thinking that this is an issue
which slows down, it slows.
And then you look up and as two
people look up and say, hey, man
it's only two.
And it's like, oh,
I guess
we got to do something about tha
But the individual owners
don't necessarily
want to have to be the one to do
They want to hire
the guy that they wanted to.
I say all that to say,
unless somebody
is going to take them to court,
I don't feel like they'll
be truly dedicated to fixing the
But I do think that right now,
when you look at the ranks,
it does look better than it did
just a couple of years ago.
But it was only two coaches,
and now it's only six minority c
And one and one of them is an in
coach of the Panthers.
What would you do?
What would you do
instead if the Rooney Rule
is not working,
but the Rooney Rule
is not the Rooney Rule, that's n
Well, you talked about the owner
and you talked about the owners.
You write in the
I mean, remember the Jerry Jones
Washington Post piece?
And Don and we we had the report
We were talking a lot.
And he told The Washington Post
admitted there is more
that I could do to really lead c
on this in the league.
Yeah.
Well,
I think some steps have actually
that the NFL doesn't
quite get enough credit for one.
There are a lot more black coord
in the NFL now than they were be
And that's typically
the track and position
that gets you to head coach.
Now, I don't have
the numbers in front of me,
but they're disproportionately
defensive coordinators,
which does not necessarily track
to being a head coach in the sam
But I do think
we've seen some improvements
in the assistant ranks.
Like, I don't just want to say
the league has done absolutely n
Like I think there are people
that recognize.
But the thing that's
going to have to improve
and the thing that's going to ha
I don't know if fix is the right
The people in charge
have to think that this matters.
Now, my thought is
they're really bad at hiring coa
I would turn it over every stone
if I could
whatever they've been doing
before, had not been working,
get desperate
enough to call it a black and br
So I get this point.
You got to realize, hey, maybe I
not that good at finding good
white coaches.
Maybe I need to try my hand over
with the black dudes.
I might be a little bit better a
I would give that a run, right?
If I'm not good at doing it one
Let's just. We'll try anything.
That would be my play.
Instead, you get the Houston Tex
who decide,
Well, we go hire
black coaches win
when nobody else will take our j
Yeah, well,
you know, the first part
you said ain't going to happen.
People like to hire people who t
You know, people do.
But also, sometimes
people like to be the one that h
that super
duper bright eyed,
super duper one to figure it out
Thank you.
You always make us wiser.
And you had this whole studio
cracking up here, Johnnie Cochra
because these
are just a lot of Texans to engi
apparently by any.
Thank you. Thank you.